i actually wasn't going to talk about
this today because my priority as many
of you know is
bringing the left together to defeat
donald trump and i thought
over the weekend when i saw the story
that talking about it might
be divisive but now that i'm seeing some
of the reactions i'm realizing that i
have to talk about it
to try to stop the divisiveness so let's
get right into it
in my mind noam chomsky has never made
more sense
than he has made in the last six months
in terms of
the urgency and the importance of voting
and of removing donald trump and he's
spoken really astutely and poignantly
to the anti-biden left to the never
biden left to people who in 2016 thought
there was no practical difference
between donald trump and hillary clinton
and he recently said and i'm
paraphrasing here
that while you might be frustrated that
you would have to lobby biden to be more
left
that under trump your city might just be
underwater and it's hard to be an
activist
for anything you care about if your city
is underwater and this was metaphorical
in nature but it lines up 110
with what i've been saying to everybody
for years now so noam chomsky was
interviewed on a podcast by brianna joy
gray
who was previously on the bernie
campaign and a guy named virgil texas
who i'm not familiar with but i
understand he's on
uh the chapo podcast which i've i've
never seen actually but i believe is is
sort of prominent in some parts of the
left
and they argued with him about
approaches to the election and after
the interview all sorts of divisive
leftist takes came out
saying chomsky lost this debate
and people should not vote for joe biden
and it's really been depressing to see
so let's look at the first clip and talk
about it what are the long-term
consequences
of everybody on the broad left democrats
liberals
everyone saying that under any
circumstances
we will vote for a democratic candidate
as long as they are incrementally better
than the republican candidate
does that way of thinking contribute to
the rightward shift
of the democratic party over years and
what mechanism will ever stop that shift
if we're not
willing to ever under any circumstances
leverage our votes
what you're saying if you think it
through is
we should help trump win because maybe
in the long run that'll affect the
democratic party
that's a terrible choice so this is
merely
dressed up accelerationism it's taking
a lame dry cookie and putting good
frosting on it so to speak it's the idea
that by punishing the democratic party
and the country mind you
since you're conceding it would be
incrementally better to have biden
but you're choosing something else
you're saying punish the country
punish people the planet so that maybe
at some future point
things get so bad that then it really
moves to the left in the united states
it hasn't worked in history and noam
chomsky
lays it out here helping trump win
as you're proposing would mean four more
years of destruction of the environment
getting possibly the tipping points that
which would be irreversible
certainly making any effort to deal with
it very difficult
it would mean stacking the judiciary
with young ultra-right lawyers
top to bottom so that nothing would be
possibly done for a generation
and i can go on and on i don't think
that's a wise choice
just on the hope that maybe sometime in
the long term
the democratic party will pay attention
to the fact that you're
part of the 50 of non-voters what noam
chomsky is talking about are the
irreversible damages
irreversible climate damage not
irreversible
but at least irreversible for decades
rightward shifts in the judiciary by
giving trump
more judges in a second term there are
millions and millions of americans who
can't afford that
and you know i've said before this isn't
about me
i could easily say sure put trump in
another four years it'll be wacky it'll
be entertaining
my show will do better and then we'll
finally go super left in 2024
because the truth is i'm fine either way
i'll get more clicks if trump is
president
i live in massachusetts where i'm
protected
from some but not all of this stuff not
the climate stuff for sure
that would be outrageously self-centered
for me to do and noam chomsky points
that out the damage to the population
from climate and judges alone
makes this idea immoral let's look at a
little more of this
here's chomp chomsky really distilling
this very clearly
now we have a simple question do you
want
your grandchildren to survive
i think the people you're talking to say
yes i want my grandchildren
so many people's grandchildren are
already not surviving
that's
or have a chance to survive so many
people aren't thinking about living
underwater because they're
incarcerated or they're unhomed then as
an activist
your goal is to make get them to think
about it
because that is what is at stake again
crystal clear and pitch perfect is noam
chomsky
truly this is the most sense chomsky has
made
in a long time here's one other clip
with the other host virgil texas
and chomsky again explaining the urgency
of the situation and the absurdity that
another four years of trump
might bring some socialist takeover in
the next decades
if these institutions if these
capitalist institutions
result in recurring ecological crises
and existential ones as they do
then isn't the real fight against those
institutions instead of a reform that
maybe gets us over the hump in 30 years
if it were possible to lobby those in
power through
activism some kind of brokering uh those
who are
beholden to the profit motive even if it
destroys the environment
we have maybe a decade or two to deal
with the environmental crisis
is there the remotest chance that within
a decade or two
we'll overthrow capitalism it's not even
a dream
okay so the quest or the point that
you're raising
is basically irrelevant of course
let's work to try to overthrow
capitalism
it's not going to happen like that
there's a lot of work involved meanwhile
we have an imminent question
are we going to preserve the possibility
for organized human society to survive
are we going to preserve the possibility
for us
to work to overthrow capitalist
institutions
or are we going to say it's hopeless
let's quit
i prefer the first you're calling for
the second
so chomsky is just spot on and
unfortunately people that are
proclaiming that chomsky was defeated
here
it's created a second round of
cheerleading
of people feeling better about not
voting biden and it's really tragic and
as chomsky says
let's be activists for stuff once biden
wins
but if biden doesn't win our activism
goes nowhere there's no chance of
anything if trump wins and that's the
key point that chomsky is making here
let's be united around it
this is not a debate about blue no
matter who
i don't even know who's seriously saying
that
there's uh any sort of validity to blue
no matter who it's
trump and biden biden happens to be the
democratic candidate trump happens to be
the republican candidate
we've evaluated two options and picked
the better one
making this a debate about the concept
of voting for the democrat whoever they
are is ridiculous we're 21 days out
and it's biden versus trump it's not
blue no matter who or blue if this or
blue is that
really well done by noam chomsky let's
come together around it
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free there's
no catch whatsoever but
if you want privacy also offers a ten
dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a 25 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman